hi I'm Prince Ari picture and sensor  body first of all I'd like to thank  everybody for getting involved in the  hashtag feel no shame campaign a pot off  since body on today World AIDS Day my  secret is believe it or not I get  incredibly nervous before public  speaking them and I help big the crowd  or the audience and despite the fact  that I laugh and and joke all the time I  get incredibly nervous if not anxious  actually and before going into rooms  full of people when I'm wearing a seat  and now that I've confessed that I'll  probably be even more worried that  people are looking at me but thank you  very much for everyone who's taking part  and I must encourage as many people to  get involved as possible thank you  you